我们女人结婚是为了更好的生活，
更美好的未来，
我才去结这趟婚，
而不是为了说逃离原生家庭，
我不需要逃离，
因为我现在已经有自己的家了，
我是一个成年人，
我能赚钱，
我能养活自己，
我饿不死，
我有地方住，
我就有自己的家。
嗯，
我打算明年结婚，
其实结婚很突然，
我本来是没有想结婚，
但是因为我家里面的情况导致我想结婚就逃离我一个家里的情况嘛，
为啥要逃离家里，
家里是有什么让你觉得很窒息、
伤心难过的点吗？
我父母是离异了，
去年我妈妈也因病去世了，
我爸爸再婚，
我后妈她是一个什么都要管，
一到过年就要吵架，
包括我前几天过年回来以后，
我搬离家里了，
出来找工作上班，
你的后妈跟你的爸爸结婚的时候，
你多大年纪了？
八九岁左右，
后妈是属于什么都要管，
但是后妈她对你在经济上有亏待吗？
在生活上有照顾吗？
有的时候我们也不能说他什么都要管就一定是坏人，
看他管的事情对不对，
对你的成长有没有帮助，
对你的学习进步有没有推动，
除了说他管你这个点之外，
他生活上对你的关照到不到位。
有没有对你有克扣，
经济上对你怎么怎么样，
这些东西也得聊一聊，
他跟我爸再婚的时候，
他跟我爸又生了一个儿子，
我妈妈有姐姐，
我是老二，
家里还有个弟弟，
我爸再婚以后又有个儿子，
这个关己就很乱，
她自己离婚的时候，
她前面也有一个儿子，
前面那个儿子是归她的前夫了，
是不是对今年过年的时候就吵架的时候说我爸对他儿子不好，
所以对我们三个是没有任何感情的，
那咱们客观一点评价啊，
你当时八九岁，
你的弟弟更小，
你的姐姐也是未成年，
她一个女人嫁过来，
那当时不说别的，
就做饭是谁做呀，
打扫卫生谁打扫啊，
你们这衣服谁洗呀，
生活谁照顾呀，
生活的话，
我们三个都是我爷爷奶奶一直在照顾的，
上高中了，
上大学了才回到我爸身边的，
就等于你们是没有跟后妈长期生活在一起，
你们实际上是跟爷爷奶奶长期生活在一起，
对对，
上大学的时候跟我爸他们住在一起就有很多矛盾，
基本都是三天一小吵，
5天一大吵，
照理来说啊，
你看你八九岁就跟爷爷奶奶生活在一起，
跟你的后妈也没有共同生活的经历那。
他管你什么呢？
他又凭什么管你呢？
我上大学的时候，
有时候放假要回家来，
他还会说我没有给他干家务，
在家里需要一个帮他带小孩，
帮他忙里忙外吧。
直到去年的时候，
因为我妈去世了，
我那段时间其实情绪不是很高涨，
又回到家里以后，
我爸做了一个举动，
让我后面不是很想回家了，
我妈去世，
我爸自己掏了5万块钱出来，
我爸回来以后对我跟我姐姐说，
让我有时间去请我阿姨吃个饭，
去感谢她。
你爸掏了5万块钱出来是干嘛的？
5万块钱让你和你的姐姐请你的后妈吃饭，
这5万块钱是属于我爸，
她出于面子要给我妈做后事，
是不是对是是，
如果说你爸爸妈妈都已经离婚这么多年了，
分开这么多年了，
你的妈妈去世，
你的爸爸还愿意出5万块钱来给你的妈妈办后事，
这个事情确实该感谢一下你的后妈，
因为他确实侵犯了后妈的经济利益，
这是实话哦，
你琢磨一下这个关系，
本来他们两口子离婚这么多年了，
前妻去世了，
现在这个前老公要拿5万块钱出来给前妻去做后事，
这种情况下，
难道不应该感谢一下现在的这个配偶吗？
现在这个配偶的利益？
受到了损害呀，
其实我知道的，
他跟我爸结婚了这么多年，
那经济上面肯定是属于他们夫妻共同财产了，
但是前提就是这个5万块钱，
我跟我姐姐已经阻挠过我爸不用他掏，
这份钱是我跟我姐可以解决了，
但是我爸他要瞒着我后妈掏了以后，
后面又来说这件事情，
让我们做子女的去感谢他一个举动，
我问一下你的这个后妈，
她是想要上位吗？
还是说你的爸爸妈妈先离了之后他俩才好的，
他们俩属于在婚内的时候就认识了，
那你对他有敌意我能理解啊，
其实我刚开始挺祝福的，
因为父母离婚，
那时候的婚姻是没有感情的，
后面他再婚了，
我是祝福的，
但是后面我后妈的种种行为导致让我对他生活上事情我可以帮助，
但是他们的利益上的关系，
我是不想掺和的，
是这样的姑娘啊，
你的原生家庭呢，
其实也不存在什么逃不逃离的问题了，
因为你现在已经成年人了，
你今年是多大，
24岁，
你自己是干什么工作的，
是什么学历，
我是大专，
你现在是自己在做美容这方面的工作，
大概一个月能挣多少钱呢？
五六千吗？
那很好了，
那你自己是有存款呢，
有一点放在。
姐姐那边存着的，
为什么要放在姐姐那边存着呢？
因为之前我爸对于我的钱方面教育，
花了还能再赚，
但是我姐姐对我的教育，
你不存钱，
等你拿钱就生病了干嘛了？
你是没有钱在手上的，
那你名下有什么资产吗？
爸爸有给你置办什么房产啊车子啊之类的吗？
没有，
你姐姐结婚了吗？
还没有，
那你觉得你的爸爸有这个能力在你姐姐结婚，
你结婚，
你的弟弟结婚的时候给你们置办什么吗？
可以，
我爸给我自己的弟弟已经置办了两套房了，
给你弟弟置办了两套房，
那你爸爸是干什么工作的呢？
我爸是自己开厂做生意的，
他大概一年能挣多少钱？
你知道吗？
年收入他应该是在百来万左右，
那他是给你的亲生的弟弟，
就是同父同母的弟弟置办了两套房，
跟你那个同父异母的弟弟置办了什么呢？
同父异母也有一套房，
房车，
你同异母的那个弟弟才多大呀？
今年18，
那显然你父亲应该是重男轻女的呀，
从经济行为上来看，
你和你姐姐名下什么都没有啊？
对，
是的，
我爸爸今年就开始催婚，
让我姐姐结婚，
他在亲戚面前说男方的家里出多少钱，
他就陪嫁多少钱，
好，
那你的原生家庭咱们了解的不？
很多了啊，
那现在了解一下你谈的这个对象吧，
是什么情况？
我这个对象是我在读高中的时候就认识的，
大概有七年了，
他有一个弟弟，
他父母也是在贵州那边上班的，
他昨天他在他们的县城买了一套房，
在哪里？
县城在湖南，
你们俩现在是在哪里工作呢？
生活呢？
在福建，
你俩都不是建人是吧？
对，
他被从惠州调去福建那边出差的，
也就跟着他去福建，
他在湖南买了房子，
说是给你们结婚用的婚房是吗？
是的，
主要是他父母掏的首付，
大概有20多万，
那你跟他谈了7年，
那他是干什么工作的呢？
他是工程师，
那他有存款吗？
有，
他大概一个月挣多少钱呀？
1万多来块，
那你们平时呃，
有生活在一起吗？
同居吗？
还没有啊，
那你现在是自己租房子住还是跟姐姐住啊？
我是自己租房子住，
自己租房子住，
她也是自己租房子住，
是不是是，
那你们平时的消费主要谁承担呀？
一起出去吃饭呀，
旅由啊，
我跟他都是AA的，
因为我之前是没有想结婚，
但是我过完年的时候就突发奇想，
我想结婚，
他就有带我回他家里看，
但是我。
但的问题，
他有一个弟弟在小的时候生病了，
现在处于几岁小孩子的一个心智，
但是他弟弟已经成年了，
他弟弟有暴力倾向吗？
你见过他弟弟吗？
见过没有暴力倾向？
是这样的姑娘啊，
首先呢，
我们要达成一个共识，
这个共识是什么呢？
我们组建一个新的家庭，
目的是为了幸福，
是为了快乐，
是为了更好的活在这个世界上，
而不是为了逃离原生家庭，
因为你现在已经不存在原生家庭了，
我过年可以不回家，
我自己有一份工作，
有一份手艺，
我在哪个城市，
我只要租了一个小小的房间，
我就有自己的家。
如果你的目的是为了逃离原生家庭，
所以我要结婚的话，
那龙飞姐今天要打破你的这个旧观念，
我们女人结婚是为了更好的生活，
更美好的未来，
我才去接这趟婚，
而不是为了说逃离原生家庭，
我不需要逃离，
因为我现在已经有自己的家了。
我是一个成年人，
我能挣钱，
我能养活自己，
我饿不死，
我有地方住，
我就有自己的家，
理解吗？
理解，
我之前是没有想结婚的冲动，
但是在于今年过年的时候，
我爸他们吵架，
我其实很不想回家过年，
但是我们家的就一种观念，
无论如何过年一定要回家，
你需要做的是见更多的人，
交更多的朋。
有看更多的书，
看更多的电影，
你要看到这个世界上有若干种活法，
有千千万万的活法。
你爸说过年让你回家，
如果你不回家，
请问他可不可以拿五花大绑绑着你，
压着你，
让你回家可以吗？
不可以，
他最多是在经济上封锁你，
对不对？
可是你经济上已经独立了呀，
本来他也重男轻女呀，
本来他也没打算给你买房子买车呀，
本来你也不寄希望于他能给你经济上有多大的支撑啊，
他唯一能做的不就是在经济上去封锁你吗？
他封锁的住吗？
是的，
因为他对我读了我读书的时候，
给我掏了读书的钱以后，
后面没有给我任何的帮助。
所以当你不再寄望于他给你买房买车，
不再寄希望于他给你钱的时候，
你需要有自己的脑子，
有自己的思考，
有自己的想法，
不是说别人喂你吃榴莲，
你就吃榴莲，
别人喂你吃香蕉，
你吃香蕉，
别人喂你吃草莓，
你就吃草莓。
你得想一下，
我喜欢什么口味，
我想要怎么活着，
我想要什么样的生活，
得在你脑子里面长出自己的追求，
自己的渴望的，
谢谢。
第一，
不存在逃离什么原生家庭的问题，
因为你长大了，
你是一个成年人，
所有他们说的话，
他们对你产生的力量只存在于观念，
一旦你打破了这个观念，
他们说的话就跟放屁一样，
一旦你不寄希望于他们再给你钱，
再给你买房。
给你买车，
再给你任何的帮衬，
那你需要做的就是我有多大本事，
我就吃多大碗饭，
我能挣多少钱，
我就就着这个钱过什么样的生活，
我一个月能挣5000，
好，
我就租一个800的房子，
做个大开间儿就可以了，
我就不要天天叫外卖，
我就自己做饭吃，
买个鸡蛋，
买个火腿肠，
炒点辣椒，
我就自己在家做饭吃，
有多大能耐我就端多大的碗，
我把我自己养个好好的营养搭配。
现在这个社会想饿死很难的，
你稍微买点鸡胸肉，
稍微买点鸡蛋，
稍微买点这些米饭的话，
你就能活的很好了，
想饿死自己太难了，
好的，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜，
你现在谈这个男朋友的话，
我的建议是多观察，
不要着急走入婚姻，
第一，
他没有那么爱你，
他如果爱你的话，
这些年谈了七年，
都是AA制，
他不给你花钱，
第二他负担挺重的，
他有一个智商低下的弟弟，
那以后靠谁？
那你就得当儿子养，
你有没有这个本事当儿子养你？
要是今天告诉我龙飞姐，
我我一年能挣五六十万多，
一个人吃饭多一双筷子，
我觉得没什么，
那我不劝你，
但是如果说你自己养活自己都是踮着脚尖的话，
就不要给自己增加负担，
你有一颗善良的心，
我们是欣赏的，
但是你有善良的心的前提条件是你有没有这个能耐坚持这份善良。
有很多姐妹就说她弟弟也挺不容易的啊，
多可怜啊，
我要是不跟他结婚的话。
哎，
谁还能看得上他呀？
你但凡生出这样的心的时候，
你给我扇自己耳巴子，
先看看自己几斤几两，
先看看自己有没有这个金刚钻，
能不能揽这个瓷器活儿，
先看看自己有没有这个本事揣这样的菩萨心肠。
记得点赞关注哦。